so let's say we're in a very simplified
world where we have two countries
country a and country b and they're each
capable of producing apples or bananas
or some combination of them and what
this chart tells us if country a put all
of their energy behind apples in a day
they could produce three apples and if
they put all of their energy behind
bananas in a day they could produce six
bananas similarly country b if they put
all of their energy behind apples in a
day they could produce two apples and
country b if they put all of their
energy behind bananas in a day they
could produce four bananas
so given this who has the comparative
advantage in apples and who has a
comparative advantage in bananas and how
should they trade
pause this video and try to figure it
out on your own
all right so when we're thinking about
comparative advantage we really want to
think about well what is the opportunity
cost of producing an apple in each
country and what is the opportunity cost
of producing a banana in each country
and so let me make another little sub
column right over here opportunity cost
and so what is the opportunity cost of
an apple in country a
and pause the video at any point if you
get inspired
well
to produce three apples they would have
to trade off six bananas and so that
means per apple they are not producing
two bananas so this is two bananas
two
bananas i'll just write banana
bananas
per
apple and their opportunity cost for
bananas is just going to be the
reciprocal of that so 1 over 2
apples
apples per
banana and then for country b we can do
a similar calculation and you might be
noticing something interesting is about
to happen what's country b's opportunity
cost of apples
well one way to think about it if they
produce two apples that means they're
giving up four bananas or they're giving
up two bananas per apple so two
bananas
per
apple and once again if we want to think
in terms the opportunity cost of a
banana well to produce four bananas
they're giving up two apples so this is
one half of
an
apple
per
banana
per i'll just write banana right over
there
so this one is a little bit interesting
they have the same opportunity cost it
for for they have the same opportunity
cost for
apples in terms of bananas and they say
have the same opportunity cost for
bananas in terms of apples and so they
because they have the same opportunity
costs
so let me write this down same
opportunity
costs
costs there is no comparative advantage
so no
comparative advantage in either
advantage
ad vantage in either
and so based on our very simple model
here there are no
gains
from
no
gains from trade another way we could
visualize this that maybe makes it maybe
hopefully a little bit more clear so
let's let me make
one axis here i'm trying to draw a
straight line all right and then this is
my other axes right over here
and let's make
this one right over here this horizontal
one let's make this the apple's axis and
let's make the vertical one the banana's
axis
bananas
and we're saying per day
per day and this of course is apples
per
day
and so
if we look at country a let me do
country a in a new color so country a
let's say orange if they put all of
their energy behind apples they could
produce
one two maybe spread this out a little
bit they could produce
one
two
three apples in a day
if they put all of the energy behind
bananas they could produce let's just
say this is
two
four
six so that's six this is four this is
two this is three right over here let me
put put markers in between to make this
clear
so if they put all of their energy into
bananas they could produce six in a day
and so their production possibilities if
we assume
it is a linear trade-off would look
something like this and the slope right
over here this would be the opportunity
cost this would be so the slope right
over here every time we increase apples
by one we decrease bananas by two so in
this situation we would have a so the
slope
slope here is equal to well it's
actually a negative slope it's equal to
negative two
bananas
per apple so this right over here this
slope based on how i picked the axes
this is giving me the opportunity cost
for apples in terms of bananas every
time i increase an apple how many
bananas am i actually giving up so that
is my opportunity cost there and now if
we think about country b
and let me do this in a new color i'm
running out of colors country b right
over here they can either produce four
bananas or two apples or things in
between but notice it has the exact same
slope the slope is the opportunity cost
and if we switch these axes right over
here then the slope would be the
opportunity cost for bananas in terms of
apples but the big takeaway here if you
see the production possibilities of two
countries and they have and we're
talking about two goods and they have
the same slope then that means our
opportunity costs are going to be the
same and there's not going to be a gain
from trade remember the whole point of
comparative advantage and trading is
that both countries will benefit that's
really the big takeaway here but there
are situations where both countries
wouldn't benefit because they have the
same opportunity cost and this was an
example of one of them now the other
case sometimes they will have one will
have a comparative advantage over the
other they do have different opportunity
costs and then you might have no gains
from trade maybe there's some way that
they can't know each other's opportunity
cost there's some way that they don't
trade maybe irrespective of what the the
models tell us about comparative
advantage some country says hey i don't
want to produce bananas apples are the
future that's a higher skilled industry
whatever else
so there's definitely scenarios
especially even in our model in our very
simplified model where there might not
be gains from trade and the classic one
of course is when there's no comparative
advantage and both countries have the
same opportunity costs in the goods